there is just too much excitement here
in the studio over the gypsy king giving
his crown back in the last couple of
hours ourselves we didn't let Jackie go
anywhere well to be honest he did have
the crown on right from the very
beginning before he'd even started the
fight but it was worth it in the end he
kept that crown as you said winning it
back the WBC belt beating Deontay Wilder
in the early hours of this morning it's
a TKO in the seventh round let's go live
to Vegas to the MGM Grand where we can
speak to the sons a sports photographer
Dickie Pelham who was right there good
morning to you Dickie and first of all
talk us through the scenes at the end of
the fight because Tyson Fury looked
really calm while there's pandemonium
going on around him it was crazy scenes
the best fight one of the best fights
I've ever photographed am i using for a
British boxers to do what he done to the
the big punch in the bronze bomber
Dion's a wild a just absolutely stalled
him it was ridiculous the fans were
going crazy like the American fans
couldn't believe what they were seeing
absolutely there were so many British
fans as well there and he reckoned about
20,000 and that ring walk talk us
through that quite funny when he came in
on the throne but what a brilliant
spectacle so
and the music the music crazy it was
just so good you know we've seen Prince
Naseem having flying through a lot of
carpet but though we expect him to come
out on the throne that was just so good
I think everyone went on each side after
that it was brilliant it was brilliant
yeah well we're looking at pictures from
the fight because he said he was going
to take it to Wilder he was going to put
him on the back foot and he did what an
amazing first round yet they don't they
just said that in the press conference
that was the game plan they told him the
game plan they were going to jump on him
from round one and that's exactly what
they did just an amazing performance
brilliant absolutely brilliant
so please for him could you see could
you see and how confident he was because
before the fight the bookies didn't
really know how to call this and they
had Wilder as the slight favorite
because never bet against a puncher as
the saying goes but you know he just
looked like he was in control he knew
what he was doing he had a plan and he
knew he was going to execute was that
the feeling you've got as you as you
watched through the lens yeah after
round after round you just it just went
so quad I and the place for the American
fans the British fans were raising it
you could see it was just a boxing
masterclass that's what we did run him a
boxing master class going to the Klump
Crump gym has raised the level again for
him he's obviously made the right
decisions there and talk us through what
happens when he dropped him the first
time what was the atmosphere like in the
third round when he knocked him down
just just shocked it was just shock that
he's just gonna knock the big bronze
bomber down it was just it was just a
scolding it was ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous as a photographer of many
fives are you starting to get excited
then thinking he's gonna finish this off
any second now yeah you got to stay
loose okay you want the big punch
picture luckily as you saw in the stills
there is a big punch picture then he's
took him into the corner for the final
flurry and luckily through the lens you
could see the towel coming once the
cells come in you know it's over
yeah Dion Sawada looks quite sort of and
confused at the end it was that there
was a lot of blood but he did look a bit
dazed is that the feeling that you got
from ringside you could
you can see was good I thought he was
concussed definitely dazed he hasn't
turned up to the press comments I think
he's gone for two stitches in the year
there may be a problem in the eardrum as
well and took us through and how we
celebrated in the ring it was funny you
obviously congratulated Deonte Walter on
a good performance
it took the belt and then he took the
microphone and started to sing and sang
the song it's a good song he's got the
secret song as an even what a something
it was amazing it was amazing
he sang American Pie he's a brilliant
voice isn't he yeah he's got hit with
Robbie Williams isn't he for Christmas
so you know Robbie Williams is no
Maggie's gonna have a good singer he's
such a showman so you've just an empty
arena now empty key but you've just come
from the press conference lots of
questions being asked about whether
there's going to be a rematch so will
there be a third fight between Tyson
Fury the now champion and Deontay Wilder
the defeated champion What did he say
about that very thing Cole and Frank
Warren both said he has 60 days to
respond whether he wants to rematch
after that who knows if we could get the
big one that the Brits or want a J
versus Tyson period but wild I had 60
days to respond to see if he wants the
rematch now they're talking about this
as one of the biggest fights you know in
the last decade in Vegas but how big
would it be if there is no rematch and
they can they can get this fight on
between AJ and Tyson Fury how big would
that be in world boxing you know that's
a Wembley Stadium times two you could
sell it out couldn't you but you know
there there could be Saudi Arabia that
could be the problem could MIT that
could be the problem we've been there
once is a lot of money generated in
Saudi Arabia but you know at fire bar
that has to go at the windy side but it
cost Tyson Fury Dwight what is well
money Old Trafford in Manchester that
would be amazing to UM Dickie thanks
very much for your thoughts thanks for
rushing for the press conference and he
probably got a lot of work to do and
really thank you for your time this
morning and Tyson Fury said he was going
off to celebrate with a slice of pizza
which seems pretty tame considering
what's gone before but there you go it's
right in here